echemos un vistazo al estéreo
selectividad de la reacción de
eliminación de dos aquí tengo un al 1
del kilo y se queme carbono alfa es el
que está unido al halógeno sabemos que
el carbono beta es el que está junto al
alfa así que este es el carbono beta
tiene dos hidrógenos y este también es
un carbono beta en un momento nos
preocupamos por el carbono de la
izquierda pero por ahora enfoquémonos en
el carbono beta de la derecha tiene dos
protones dos protones que pueden
participar en este mecanismo y verán que
cuando empecemos a dibujar la proyección
de newman estos protones permitirán dos
posibles conformación es por lo que
podremos obtener diferentes productos y
se favorecerá un estero y somero ese es
el concepto de estéreo selectividad
dibujemos nuestras proyecciones de
newman pondré un ojo aquí y vamos a
mirar hacia el enlace alfa beta
miraremos hacia acá este enlace tratemos
de dibujar la proyección de newman para
eso recuerden que pueden usar su modelo
molecular si les cuesta trabajo o
también pueden ver los vídeos anteriores
para aprender a dibujar las proyecciones
de newman empecemos con este carbono hay
un bromo que va hacia la derecha y luego
está el grupo metil hacia abajo los
hemos identificado rápido el bromo está
hacia la derecha y el hidrógeno hacia la
izquierda después tenemos al grupo metil
hacia abajo y ahora ponemos el carbono
beta lo representamos con un círculo en
nuestra proyección de newman
ahí está y que sale del carbono beta
bueno hay un grupo metido lo podemos
dibujar por aquí
un grupo metil y después tenemos dos
hidrógenos uno que va hacia la derecha y
otro que va hacia la izquierda ahora me
gustaría que re dibujemos la proyección
de newman sin cambiar nada solo
girándola un poquito
quiero que el bromo quede arriba
y así el hidrógeno que de abajo no estoy
cambiando la conformación solamente
estoy poniendo el bromo arriba si
ponemos el bromo arriba en la proyección
de newman que nos queda bueno
pongamos el carbono aquí queda el
hidrógeno originalmente del lado derecho
está el bromo pero ahora el grupo metil
nos queda hacia la derecha
y para el carbono de atrás tenemos un
mitin entre el hidrógeno y el bromo
quizá el grupo metil
y este es un hidrógeno
y otro hidrógeno una vez más no hay
realizado ninguna rotación solo he
cambiado el punto de vista aquí está la
proyección de newman si quieren podemos
dibujarla en una proyección de caballete
que es más fácil para visualizar
dibujemos una proyección de caballete
aquí está el carbono de adelante este es
el carbono frontal ahora esta vez el
carbono de atrás quedará como una y algo
así entonces en el carbono de adelante
tenemos un bromo del lado izquierdo está
un hidrógeno y por acá un metil en el
carbono de atrás aquí está un metido
y luego un hidrógeno por aquí y otro por
acá ahora que ya dibujamos todo podemos
pensar en nuestro mecanismo sabemos que
el stock sido de sodio es una base
entonces la carga negativa del oxígeno
tomará el protón que está en la
conformación anti peri planner ahora que
tenemos la proyección de caballete es
más fácil identificar cuáles aquí
tenemos nuestra proyección de newman el
protón que está en la conformación anti
peri plana es el que esté en el mismo
plano que el bromo
si observamos en la proyección de newman
este es nuestro bromo y este puede ser
nuestro hidrógeno beta en la
conformación anti peri planar entonces
en nuestra proyección de caballete sería
este hidrógeno y aquí está el bromo
están en el mismo plano y en lados
opuestos aquí aparece lo anti para
dibujar el mecanismo nuestra base tomará
a este protón dejando los electrones que
se moverán para formar el doble enlace y
al mismo tiempo estos se van con el
bromo que es el grupo saliente dibujemos
los productos de esta reacción será un
al que no y podemos ver que los dos
grupos metilo quedaron en lados opuestos
respecto al doble enlace eso se vería
fácil en la proyección de newman el
doble enlace se forma entre nuestro
carbono de adelante y el carbono de
atrás y los grupos metilo terminaron en
lados opuestos así hemos formado un
estero y somero trans este es nuestro
estéreo y somero trans un posible
producto que se puede formar con este
carbono beta
recuerden que aún hay otro protón beta
que nos interesa pero primero regresemos
a la proyección de newman que teníamos
en la derecha veamos si podemos aplicar
alguna rotación para obtener el producto
cis recuerden que todos estos enlaces
simples pueden rotar libremente haré que
este mitin rote hacia acá dibujemos
nuevamente si yo quiero mover el grupo
metilo de aquí necesito rotar los
carbonos de atrás
el mitin a esta posición
necesito rotar el carbono de atrás
dibujemos como nos queda el carbono de
adelante lo dejamos tal y como está por
aquí está el bromo luego el hidrógeno y
el grupo metilo ok después en el carbono
de atrás el que ya rotamos el met y
quedó aquí roto a este lado eso
significa que este es un hidrógeno y
aquí el otro hidrógeno así queda otra
posible conformación la pregunta es cuál
es nuestro protón anti peri planar para
este caso bueno ahora que este protón se
encuentra en el mismo plano que el bromo
entonces si dibujamos la proyección de
caballete para este caso aquí está el
carbono de adelante así
y luego el carbono de atrás queda
nuevamente con la forma que pongamos
nuestros grupos
sabemos que el bromo está aquí este es
el hidrógeno y éste es el metil en el
carbono de atrás sabemos que este es el
hidrógeno este servicio y este es un
hidrógeno veamos como sería el mecanismo
vamos a dibujar el año net óxido
que está cargado negativamente un par de
sus electrones tomará el protón ante y
pery planar que ya vimos en la
proyección de caballete este de aquí la
carga negativa tomará este protón y una
vez más estos electrones se moverán para
formar el doble enlace al mismo tiempo
que sale nuestro halógeno cuál es el
producto final bueno estos grupos metilo
ahora están del mismo lado si pensamos
en la conformación del doble enlace será
más fácil verlo en la proyección de
newman aquí se formó el doble enlace y
esta vez los grupos metilo terminaron
del mismo lado
este es por supuesto el producto cis
entonces ya tenemos el producto trans y
el cis pero cuál de estos dos se
producirá en mayor cantidad
bueno como ya hemos visto el producto
trans es más estable por lo que habrá
mayor cantidad de trans si regresamos a
las proyecciones de newman aquí tenemos
un grupo metilo que está anti respecto a
este están lo más alejados que pueden
uno del otro así que esta es la mejor
conformación sí hablamos de estas dos
conformación es la flecha será más larga
hacia la izquierda porque esta
conformación es más estable y una flecha
más pequeña irá hacia la derecha a la
derecha están los dos grupos metilo
relativamente cerca uno del otro
lo que genera un montón de dificultades
terika así que la conformación de la
derecha no es tan favorecida como la de
la izquierda por lo tanto el producto
trans se producirá en mayor cantidad y
el producto 6 en menor cantidad para
esta reacción aún nos falta un posible
producto que se obtiene con el otro
carbono beta como pueden ver todo esto
que hicimos fue basándonos en estos dos
protones y pudimos ver la stereo
selectividad de esta reacción para el
estéreo y somero trans pero aún tenemos
un carbono beta con hidrógenos beta así
que aún nos falta un producto será más
fácil porque no tenemos que preocuparnos
por dibujar todas estas proyecciones de
newman dibujemos esta reacción
rápidamente tampoco tenemos que
preocuparnos por la estéreo química
aquí están nuestros 4 carbonos y el
bromo está por aquí sabemos que este es
nuestro carbono alfa y este es nuestro
carbono beta también sabemos que hay un
montón de hidrógenos beta escogeremos
uno digamos que este es nuestro
hidrógeno beth nuevamente usamos el
stoke sido de sodio como base vamos a
dibujarla aquí está nuestro tóxico que
tomará a este protón y así estos
electrones se moverán hacia acá al mismo
tiempo que el bromo se irá
al final nos queda este producto el
doble enlace se forma entre nuestro
carbono alfa y este carbono beta es un
al que no mono sustituido de todos los
productos será el que se produzca en
menor cantidad
así que obtuvimos un producto mono
sustituido y los estéreo isómeros 6 y
trans estos dos stand y sustituidos y ya
sabíamos que se formaran en mayor
cantidad que el producto mono sustituido
esta es la estéreo selectividad en la
reacción de eliminación es 2